One point I want to stress in the distinction between sketching with
the visualization and something like EDA is that exploratory data analysis is
typically performed, when you are exploring the structure and values of the data
to find insights, erroneous values or are there features of your dataset.
That are inherent to the form of the data itself.
Sketching in contrast is performed to experiment with
the visual display of the data and explore the best visual encodings for
the given data values and types.
One last point about the distinction between something like EDA and sketching.
Is the EDA is often thought of between yourself and the data.
It's for you to discover insights in your data and
figure out the right questions to ask.
Sketching, on the hand, is to communicate some insights to others.
This is iterating and prototyping the best way to
visually display some insight that you have all ready found.
This is somewhat similar to the distinction that the grammar of
graphics makes between the data and the aesthetic.
Think of sketching as iterating on the visual aesthetic, and
EDA as iterating on the data, itself.
Do you think a scatter plot is better suited for this data than a bar plot.
Often people use a scatter plot to display time series and distributions.
And while it can work for these types of things,
just like a chef wouldn't use a butcher's knife to cut vegetables.
I think that scatter plot is better suited for
data, where each field on the x axis is not correlated with itself.
What do I mean by this exactly?
Well, given time,
one year is implicitly dependent on the year that came before it.
A subtle distinction about why not to use a scatter plot for this data set.
Is similar to a lot of the choices that front-end designers, make for
common user interface best practices.
For example, it's very rare that you see a site with the horizontal scroll
going left to right rather than vertically up to down.
If you've seen MySpace's new site redesign.
You'll know that they're an exception, and the reason why sites often don't do
this is, because it can be very disorienting for a user, since 99% of sites,
probably more out there, scroll vertically if a user scrolls the mouse up or
down rather than horizontally, and they come to expect this behavior for
every site.
If a site maps scrolling up and down to actually horizontal action on the page,
from left and right.
It's not wrong or incorrect, but simply just unconventional.
And in this same vein, if people come to know a scatter plot
to represent data where the x values are uncorrelated and
independent, they might assume that the data that you've chosen to
represent by a scatter plot has x values that are independent and uncorrelated.
So in this case, a scatter plot actually succumbs to the same issues as
the bar plot, and actually doesn't highlight the missing data as well.
So it might be even a little worse in my opinion.